starting today southern nevadans who
qualify can get a vaccine booster shot
that's right it's only for those who
have had the pfizer vaccine bianca
holman joining us live in the newsroom
with all the details bianca
hey good morning heather good morning
john clark county reaching a great
milestone recently 70 percent of
residents here have at least one dose of
the vaccine starting today like you said
several pharmacies like walgreens will
provide nevadans their pfizer coven 19
booster you must have completed your two
dose series of the pfizer vaccine at
least six months ago those who qualify
must be 65 years and older also those 18
to 64 who have underlying conditions or
have a job that puts them at risk to
exposure of the virus they can also get
a booster shot some are ready for the
booster others still hesitant
i think it's wonderful since i'm a
diabetic and
older i'm
considering getting the third one i
don't know what difference
is it going to make
i don't think there's enough that enough
people have gotten it in order
for me to make a decision on how many
people are benefiting from it
the health district says the kobit 19
vaccine is the best way to slow the
spread of the coronavirus doctors also
urge wearing and still encourage people
to wear your mask wash your hands and
stay home if you are sick and now
statewide there are 55 percent of those
who are eligible are fully vaccinated
we've got more about the booster shot
coming up in the next half hour bianca
holman live local now